good morning john one of the weird
things about being on tick tock is that
because the group of people there is
literally just different people
oftentimes younger people there are
sometimes conversations i see being had
that i have had like pretty much
everybody i know is done with that
conversation but they haven't had it yet
so they're having to have it this
happened recently when i saw a tick tock
uh arguing whether to say jiff or gif
and and i am at least five years into
having heard everything you can say
about that and having settled upon both
are correct so i did actually get a
little bit pissed off when i heard again
the well it's not giraffix interchange
format it's graphics interchange format
so it must be gif that's not how
acronyms work i don't care how you
pronounce gif but i do care if your
argument is garbage but this is not the
point that i want to make my point is
that there are some things that
definitely don't matter we know they
don't matter but they're jarring when we
come across people doing them
differently like when i see a screenshot
of light mode twitter i'm like what what
are you thinking smiley face without
noses i don't like it other people don't
like me doing smiley faces with noses
cowboy bebop subtitled versus dubbed at
england now look i'm not saying that
there aren't legitimate reasons why
these things are different like the
experience of subtitled cowboy bebop is
different from the experience of english
dub gif makes sense because if you put a
t on it it's gif jif makes sense because
that's what the developer of the format
called it taking the toilet paper off
the front makes it a little bit easier
to take off having it on the back makes
it so that your cat can't like do this
and just have it all come on i'm not
saying there aren't differences here
what i'm saying is that the way that i
do it is the way that i think everybody
should do it and i'm gonna come up with
reasons why that's better people can
argue all day about whether subtitled or
dubbed cowboy bebop is better but the
one that they like is the one that they
watched first light mode twitter looks
normal if that's what you're used to
using dark mode looks normal if that's
what you're used to using the thing
that's bugging us it's not all these
rationalizations it's just the fact that
it's different and i'm not saying that
we're bad because we're irrational i'm
just saying that we're irrational and
the fact that things this simple that do
not affect our lives at all can make our
brains go oh no something is wrong i
don't like it i think it shows like how
hard it is to do society how are we as a
species supposed to get anything done
when things that don't even matter cause
these little mini protests in our brains
i can't watch english dubbed cowboy
bebop even though i know that it is very
good and that many people make the case
that it is objectively better than the
original version i can't do it it's like
fingernails on a chalkboard it's like i
know that i'm being and i know that i'm
being irrational i don't want you to
think that like this is me being a
hipster no i know that it's stupid and i
will never say gif i will never say gif
i just won't when i think about it this
way it is absolutely amazing that we get
anything done at all things that
actually matter are so hard just on
their own but then you've got like also
to include all these little irrational
biases that we have and are going to
have and can't get rid of we are really
deeply controlled by wanting things to
be the way that we expect them to be
whether that is like how the economy
works or whether a smiley has a nose but
that stuff is never going to be
universal because the world is
complicated and varied and weird and it
should be weird i like it because it's
weird here's a definitely true thing
no two people have ever agreed on
everything ever and yet we have managed
to get quite a lot done which gives me
hope that in the future despite all of
this we will continue to get stuff done
john i'll see you on tuesday john it's
the next day and it's the first time in
ages that i have ended a vlogbrothers
video and had time
like this is shocking i don't know what
to do i guess what i'll do is to remind
everybody to go watch your video from
last week which was really lovely and
thoughtful and beautiful and i was very
touched by it
thank and and i'm gonna thank everybody
for joining the awesome socks club look
if you're a current member you get these
cool froggy ones but if you just joined
your first sock will come in january